alors ça y est elle est belle croix
ça y est c'est signé hier à midi à la
fessée vous pas un poil comme borne pas
à faire regarder car l'hymne est fier
tout ça vous l'envoyer au service
comptabilité
momo se dire une chose on apprendra plus
d'accord voyons les i les parents de
venir devant vous feriez vous allez
comprendre pied stéphane bern et
tant pis si vous jugez pas d'après
à 11 ans
j'étais très amoureuse quand même le
marchand
était blonde a été belle aimée quand
j'étais dingue j'en étais fou tu vois et
puis elle me tirait les cheveux et me
crachait dessus je chéris toutes les
nuits car oui toutes les nuits
karine lemarchand je la croise il ya
deux jours dans la rue san hippopotames
je vais même pas reconnu
mais ce qui vous reste effet
si vous pouviez me leur expliquer parce
que c'était pas très clair mais oui je
sais pas trop les gens du passé
vous laisser dans le passé
pour qu'il vous laisse passer
tu vois le gros qui parlent fort la
cuire or en fait qui met des claques
je veux plus le voir pour toi d'accord
oui monsieur darcis